psoriasis is a skin disease that causes
thick itchy patches of red skin with
silvery scaling
the top two layers of your skin are
called the epidermis
and dermis new cells at the bottom of
the epidermis constantly move up and
replace the older cells above them
normally it takes about a month for
cells to make this journey
in psoriasis cells reach the skin
surface in only six to eight days
because of a problem with your immune
system
scientists think your immune system
mistakes certain natural substances in
your skin as foreign invaders this
causes your immune system to start a
counter-attack called an inflammatory
response
inflammation is a series of changes that
happen in your skin including enlarged
blood vessels growth of more blood
vessels more immune cells in the area
forming groups and faster creation of
new skin cells
over time the process of inflammation
becomes a cycle damaged skin cells
signal more immune cells to come to the
area in turn the immune cells cause your
skin cells to multiply rapidly and your
skin to get thicker
this results in raised itchy inflamed
areas called plaques on your skin
scientists think that psoriasis is
passed down in families through parts of
your DNA called genes
you can develop psoriasis if you have
these genes then experience certain
triggers such as skin injuries dry skin
infections stress smoking and certain
medications
if you have any questions about
psoriasis talk to your health care
provider